in your work you you quote Nietzsche
quite a bit his a line he who has a why
to live for can bear almost any how what
do you think he meant by that what do
you think he meant by that the same as
I'm intended to convey to my readers and
students that the vision of a meaning
ahead of someone a meaning in wait for
someone to be fulfilled by someone but
this contributes most and anything else
and the equal other circumstances for
Survivor meaning is the most important
thing in our lives certainly because a
what I call it weird - meaning we wish
to find and to fulfill meaning is the
basic motivation in human beings well
this certainly runs counter to much of
the determinist notions that are being
bandied around these about these days as
man as a machine man as a computer man
is a product of instincts man is
something like you're at in experiments
psychological experiments of course you
are right but not only against it so
called deterministic concepts of man but
also regarding the motivational theories
of certain psychotherapeutic system
let's talk for a minute about
logotherapy
which arose out of this notion of a
search for meaning global therapy is one
among other types of psychotherapy is we
may say a meaning centered psychotherapy
in as much particularly as local therapy
sees you a human being not predominantly
determined not to say dominated by the
will to pleasure as you were mentioning
know
by the will to power along the lines of
our Aryan teachings but basically
fundamentally by a will to meaning
that is to say the desire the impulse to
find to discover in life or better to
say in each life situation concrete life
situation confronting someone the desire
to find a meaning terrain and going and
to go on to fulfilling I was very
intrigued one of the most surprising
things I've read recently was that you
said that when you talk to European
students only 40 percent said they had
suffered this sort of inner void and yet
eighty-one percent of American students
experience the same thing that we think
to go we think of it just the opposite
we think of the Europeans as being
buried under this existential dread and
sense of purpose lessness and Americans
is being optimistic and upbeat
however it might be whether the one or
one's or the others are suffering more
or less respectively from this
existential vacuum the ones who seem to
suffer less should not look at the
others with contempt but look at the
others with compassion and look for
anything possible to help the others now
this void manifests itself as in apathy
apathy in boredom lack of initiative
lack of interest interest in the world
or initiative in changing something
within the world for the better this
frustration is a a proof of the
existence of a will to meaning unless we
we're imbued by will - meaning by the
wish to find meaning and discuss
discover and fulfill meaning in life
when
would be able to experience an inner
void so this is in a way also something
positive
now you've listed three types of values
creative values experiential values and
attitudinal variants you may find a
meaning the average man the man of the
street or the woman in the street may
find a meaning day by day in doing a
deed in creating a work and that's the
creative creative and in experiencing
something the beauty the truth is a
researcher or the good in dealing with
people as a teacher there's an
extraordinary moment in man's search for
meaning when you talk about being in one
of the one of the Nazi camps and all of
you going out to look at a sunset is
that exactly in Japan digne of
experiential values of finding a meaning
in experiencing without doing anything
without achieving or accomplishing
anything but just in giving oneself the
immediate experience of something goes a
beautiful going on in the world this is
the second Avenue but there is also it a
is a another aspect of experiential
values excuse me not only experiencing
something but also experiencing someone
more than that experience
experiencing another human being in his
or her very uniqueness and it is the
main attribute of a human being that he
is a person in contrast to any animal he
is a person a person is always something
absolutely unique irreparable in the
evolution of the cosmos as is we are
incomparable with any other human being
and his uniqueness can be got hold of
solely by a loving person because he not
only sees the essence but also the
potentials in the beloved
thereby as I put it before promoting him
alleviating it to reach out to attain
this potential and to fulfill and
thereby actualize also himself but not
by preaching self-actualization it's
nonsense
self-actualization can only fall into
your lap automatically once that you
have fulfilled a concrete meaning than
the best of a situation then you actor
lies yourself is a by-product let's talk
about the third set of values which is
the attitudinal the idea of choosing how
to respond to suffering
choosing the attitude yes if there is no
possibility in a given situation to
fulfill the meaning of a situation by
giving oneself to the experience of
beauty and so forth
no Allah - if you have lost the
capability to do your job to do your
work even then there is an ultimate
possibility to find in fulfilment
fulfill meaning not only the ultimate it
is even the potential to fulfill the
deepest meaning to attain the highest
values by the you approach to the
different to this situation a tragic or
tryst situation confronting you you said
that in part of the initial shock of
being put in a death camp was there was
it was ultimately an acceptance that we
knew we knew we had nothing to lose
except our ridiculously naked lives is
that the situation that they're in in
your way is this what you is this when
you make the choice of how you go into
your last value choices how to react to
the situation stand there you stood
there naked with nothing you could have
had but all the more what counted and
the method was what
we're being rather than having
possessing anything the be so it what
counted was what you make out of the
situation with what attitude you adopt
in the DV situation and there is a
multitude a wealth of possible attitudes
to how to approach it so we have to
decide the ultimate I would take it add
to no value challenge that we all share
is how we're going to face death how do
you prepare people for that how do you
prepare yourself for that
I couldn't prepare anyone else and law
said unless I would have prepared myself
because you are if you a psychiatrist
your patients feel exactly whether or
not you are really convinced of what you
are teaching and telling them now I'm
convinced that in contrast to the usual
aspect or beat sound aspect to life and
more pert and more specifically to the
past to life's transitoriness and this
includes that we approach each of us are
approaching death in contrast to that I
maintain that in the past nothing is
lost but right on the contrary
everything is stored forever
it is not annihilated by transitoriness
but on the contrary it has been it is
becoming preserved forever something you
have done can never be undone something
you have experienced something you have
even experienced in a negative sense
going through suffering and if your
entity we've suffered again through this
suffering
honestly courageously and with dignity
who in the world what what in the world
can deny
I can annihilate this what you have done
has been done forever
in both ways in a negative as in a
positive way it cannot it cannot be
undone and the past is a storehouse of
what you have done what you have
experienced what you have gone through
and what you have done out of all the
negative and tragic aspects as even
encountered within your life someone
thank you for being on the show
and I want to thank you at home for
watching